merci à tous et à tout est vraiment ravi
d'être parmi vous alors ce que je vais
vous raconter c'est un peu comme un
conte de fées bon sauf que ça démarre
très très mal mais je préfère vous
prévenir
ça démarre vraiment très très mal quand
je suis né ma mère psychiatrique menthe
malades père inconnu sur décision de
justice
je suis placé à la dass qui me place
dans une poule pommery puis ensuite dans
une famille d'accueil dans un village
normand pendant quelques années
alors pendant mon enfance
ce qui m'a sauvé c'est les vaches quand
j'avais chercher du lait à la ferme
j'adorais chanter des chansons aux
vaches je vous assure
bonjour les vaches
vous me reconnaissez c'est moi
la petit et l'ina hier encore j'ai joué
au bois avec le grand monsieur
il m'a donné plein beaucoup de bonbons
plein de caresses étant de chatouilles
mais ce matin je ne sais tu pas pourquoi
je ne suis pas très bien à 14 ans je
suis exclu du système scolaire
et oui l'éducation nationale décrète que
j'ai des problèmes psychomoteurs
j'ai tout fait j'ai j'ai dit mais je
vous en prie j'étais en seconde je
disais mais laissez-moi laissez-moi
redoublé surtout que moi je rêvais de
faire des études parce que très vite
j'ai compris dans cette famille
d'accueil où ils savaient à peine lire
et écrire ou la culture n'existait pas
et chaque fois qu'elle vit des parisiens
qui menaient dans mon village je me
disais qu'est ce qu'ils ont l'air
intelligent ces gens là je me suis dit
c'est les études qui vont me sauver bon
pas de chance on mise plus du système
scolaire et là je commence mes fugueurs
jeu de 14 ans à 18 ans j'alterne les
fugues et les foyers de l'institution à
18 ans le jour de mes 18 ans je suis à
la rue parce que voilà à la dass c'est
comme ça pour beaucoup d'enfants qui
sont placés la majorité est un critère
pour aller à la rue alors pendant un an
j'ai fait ce qu'on appelle de la rue
sèche de 18 ans à 19 ans est bien la rue
sèche c'est quoi c'est aller au hasard
des rues ou hasard des rencontres
et puis à un moment donné il faut
trouver les techniques de survie alors
moi par exemple je vais vous en citer
quelques unes
elle avait une qui marche à tous les
coups je repérais une femme
sympa oui parce que les femmes sont plus
sympas que les hommes
et là regardez bien et je prenais mon
courage à deux mains et je courrai le
coin je pourrais encore et le coin à
laval on m'a volé mon sac montre mes
enfants m'attendent et hop d'iso aussi
faut savoir que du lundi au jeudi
dans les boîtes de nuit c'est gratuit
pour les filles
mais attention moi j'allais dans les
boîtes de nuit c'était pas pour danser
c'était pour dormir et puis vous
imaginez bien que je dans les boîtes de
nuit j'ai rencontré des hommes
et donc quand j'étais dans le caca le
vendredi le samedi ou le dimanche
eh ben j'appelais celui que j'avais
rencontré le lundi ou le mardi ou
mercredi
voilà et quand j'en avais marre de tout
ça je me je me remplissait de couches et
je me faisais le plus moche possible et
je me tapais les lignes de métro de bout
en bout
pour paco m'emmerde et ça a marché bref
dans la rue faut savoir que j'ai
continué bien entendu jusqu'à mes 19 ans
à faire ce que j'avais appris pendant
toute mon enfance
et puis tout ça ça m'a valu à 19 ans une
tutelle de juge jusqu'à 21 ans j'ai
rencontré un juge qui m'a dit et l'ina
on va s'occuper de toi promis
tu retournes plus dans la rue mais une
seule condition que tu ailles voir un
psychiatre deux fois par semaine bon
j'avais pas trop le choix de toute façon
mais aujourd'hui encore je remercie ce
juge pour enfants parce que il m'a pas
donné le choix
il m'a dit c'est comme ça point barre et
grâce à lui
ça m'a recadré g j'ai compris ce
qu'était la notion de la loi j'ai
compris un peu mieux la société
j'ai compris que pour s'en sortir ben
fallait peut-être travailler il fallait
peut-être arrêter de d'être victime de
dire toujours c'est la faute à l'autre
et puis 21 ans arrive retour à la rue
donc là
vaille que vaille voilà je les centres
d'urgence favon la rue c'est tellement
long à raconter
bref à 25 ans dans toutes mes rencontres
je rencontre marie desplechin qui à
l'époque n'était absolument pas connu
qui cherchait une une baby sitter contre
une chambre de bonne de 7 mètres carrés
il y avait qu un lavabo mais moi ça
m'était égal
le principal c'est que j'avais un toit
sauf que elle elle savait pas que je me
droguais savais pas que je que je
fréquente et des voyous ne savais pas
que femme que j'étais dans plein de
galère et puis un jour elle a observé
que l'aluminium disparaissait souvent et
elle s'est renseignée
comment savoir d'être douce des doutes
sur moi et l'âge tout à coup il m'est
revenu
l'histoire du contrat ce que m'avait
appris le juge
et j'ai dit écoute mari je te promets je
me drogue plus mais en échange tu me
promets je retourne pas la rue m dit
d'accord ok si tu te rends tu pues tuera
plus dans la rue et là j'arrête de me
droguer et après évidemment j'ai déprimé
je vais pas vous dire que c'était facile
et là je suis retourné chez le
psychiatre donc ça a duré bien deux ans
à un moment donné marie des peluches à
déménager dont j'ai dû retourner dans la
rue mais se retrouve à l'armée du salut
et puis à moment donné j'en ai eu marre
mais marre de tout tout le temps est à
la recherche d'un d'un truc pour trouver
un art pas de trouver un lit le soir de
de trouver une fringue de voler un rouge
à lèvres dans un magasin pour être jolie
bref j'en ai eu marre de tout ça à 30
ans je me dis mais elin à toi t'es
vachement forte tu connais tous dans le
social pourquoi tu pourrais pas être
assistante sociale et là je passe à un
brevet d'état pour devenir assistante
sociale
croyez moi j'étais convaincu que je
serai la meilleure et suite à mon
obtention de ce brevet d'état je suis
embauché dans un centre qui accueille
des jeunes filles de la rue issue entre
15 et 25 ans et là me voilà en poste et
un jour la directrice dit bon bah
écoutez ce soir cette jeune fille elle a
fait ces 4 jours vous la remettez à la
rue et moi général 1 il n'en est pas
question
moi si je fais du social c'est pour
faire la révolution c'est pas pour
appliquer tout ce qu'on vous dit de
faire et puis je me suis battu je me
suis battu contre l'institution
puis un jour on m'a dit écoute et lina
si t'es pas content tu démissionnes j'ai
démissionné et à nouveau je me retrouve
à la rue ce canton démissionne
évidemment la loi rien et je me suis dit
je vais jamais mon sortir quoi
hélas comme je connaissais quand même
pas demain je connaissais pas de
beaucoup de gens dans le milieu du
social à 30 ans je vais voir une femme
qui s'occupait de femme battue et je lui
ai dit écoute moi je sais pas ce que je
vais devenir
voilà là t'as vu j'ai tout fait pour
m'en sortir là j'ai passé une formation
jette une remise à niveau en français
j'ai fait des cours de français et tous
et elle me dit va écouter l'hymne à
qu'est ce que tu aimes dans la vie alors
je lui dis bah j'aime bien chanter
j'aime bien les enfants
j'aime bien rigoler j'aime bien
m'occuper des autres enfin bref et là il
me dit écoute et l'image connaît un type
qui veut faire un projet de réinsertion
avec des sdf pour monter les bas-fonds
de maxime gorki au théâtre national de
chaillot
mais avec des vrais sdf alors moi
évidemment là j'étais la bonne personne
du coup je vais aller chercher tous mes
potes je les ai tous présentés au
metteur en scène est le metteur en scène
l'a dit mais c'est génial et l'a dit
banco et nous voilà partis sur un projet
pour 2 pendant un an et le projet était
partagé en deux le but c'était de se
réinsérer
il y avait une autre partie par le biais
du théâtre de deux
et cette pièce de théâtre fin de la joue
et de l'interpréter puisque les
bas-fonds de maxime gorki pour ceux qui
ne le savent pas ça raconte la misère en
russie du 19e siècle et donc nous voilà
donc la faut vous imaginer on est une
trentaine de sans domicile fixe à bouger
dans tous les sens c'est un peu le boxon
je vous cache pas parce qu'on n'arrête
pas de boire comme ça faut savoir par
exemple défendent arrivé complètement
bourré aux répétitions mais on voulait y
arriver parce qu'on disait pour une fois
on va nous regarder avec des yeux
nouveaux quoi et et on était fier de se
montrer sur scène
d'ailleurs suite à ça on a été médiatisé
à travers le monde entier pour vous dire
j'ai eu un un article en japonais non
mais c'est vrai je vous ment pas et le
but de cette opération qui a duré quand
même un an et demi c'était que les gens
qui viennent nous voir et envie de nous
tendre la main un logement une chambre
de bonne
un petit travail sauf que la presse
évidemment au lieu de nous lever vers le
haut elle a pointé toutes les bêtises
qu'on avait fait par exemple je raconte
j'avais un pote quel effet 15 ans de
prison pour braquages mois il avait
raconté tout mais tout tout ce qu'il
fallait pas raconter ça que que je
m'étais drogué à la cocaïne que je
connaissais toutes les boîtes à
partouzes que j'avais volé enfin bref
c'est sûr les gens allaient pas venir
comme ça venir nous voir pour nous faire
confiance et pourtant ils auraient pu
parce qu'on était en train où on était
en train de vouloir s'en sortir
bon bref janvier 99 le temps que tout ça
soit digéré la colère me vient et moi
j'ai toujours été révolté par
l'injustice je me dis moi je vais
l'écrire mon spectacle et je vais
raconter l'humanité des sans domicile
fixe de l'intérieur je raconte est un
peu au monde
qu'est ce que ça veut dire être sans
domicile fixe
et j'ai mis dix ans à écrire ce
spectacle alors comment j'ai fait
pendant ces dix ans parce que j'avais
toujours pas de toit
mais cette marie desplechin qui avait
aidé cette femme pour qui j'avais gardé
ses enfants entre temps l'avait fait un
best seller en racontant mon histoire et
entre temps laver elle avait investi
dans l'immobilier
vous savez les petites chambres de bonne
à paris la con qu'on casse et puis après
on fait des grand appart les étés
pourris et moi julien marie je t'en prie
laisse-moi louer un petit goûter lina tu
vas pas vivre dans un taudis les gens
m'en fous je m'en fous moi le principal
c'est que j'avais à mur
et puis point barre et puis il fallait
que je m'en ce projet alors me voilà
dans cette chambre de bonne
allez là on va dire je suis passé à 12
m² toujours sans lavabo sans douche mais
je m'en foutais j'avais une envie dans
ma tête c'était d'aller au bout de mon
projet pendant ces dix ans je me suis
soigné psychiatre les a enfin tous les
docteurs qui existe parce que vous savez
que la rue malheureusement développent
des maladies là la claustrophobie
l'agoraphobie enfin bon des crises de
panique
enfin bref donc pendant dix ans je me
suis soigné pendant quatre en soins
intensifs pour mes dents et je suis très
fier j'ai payé tout seul parce qu'à
l'époque j'étais au rmi et si je me
faisais soigné avec l'argent de l'état
là j'aurai des dents en ferraille et là
on était pas question
non j'ai dit je me les payer tout seul
mais dans g bouffer des pâtes à tous les
jours et met dans les ai payés tout seul
parce que souvent les gens et 18 a vu
tout ce qu'on leur paye et tout le
social le social le social bon en
attendant moi heureusement que le social
m'a un peu aidé sinon je ne serais pas
là aujourd'hui
et puis pendant ces dix ans aussi j'ai
créé mon association en 2008 qui
s'appelle cris d'éclat moi j'ai dit je
veux faire du social à ma manière
aujourd'hui beaucoup d'associations
comme les restos du coeur serait manuel
habitat humaniste l'abbé pierre viennent
vers moi pour qu'on travaille ensemble
et ça je trouve ça génial
puisqu'à un moment donné j'étais la
première à critiquer parfois leurs
méthodes
2011 arrive alors la 2011 c'est génial
enfin j'ai mon premier appartement à 44
ans vous vous rendez compte
j'ai un vrai studio dans un hlm pour
vous dire c'est tellement difficile de
d'avoir son appartement et ben le matin
j'allais dans ma cuisine
alors que j'avais une salle de bain
c'est pour vous montrer la difficulté de
s'approprier un appartement mais bon je
me suis dit c'est pas grave s'il ya que
ça je m'en sortirai 2011
je dis allez lina faut y aller
maintenant que tu représentes ton
spectacle mais dans ma tête ça pouvait
intéresser que les travailleurs sociaux
et puis j'ai rappelé tous les
journalistes qui m'avait médiatisé en 98
il y en a un qui est venu un journaliste
de libération et il me dit en sortant ni
vie c'est génial et lil wayne qui alors
là franchement personne par le de
l'humanité des sans domicile fixe comme
tu le fais pas je vis un peu normal je
l' ai vécu quand même et puis il me dit
je te rappelle bon j'ai pas trop cru je
me suis dit lui veut sûrement coucher
avec moi c'est ça à la rue 1 on
développe un peu de paranoïa et puis il
est revenu et il a fait mon portrait
dans libé et sachez que beaucoup
d'artistes rêve d'avoir leur portrait
dans libération
suite à ça flammarion est venu vers moi
qui m'ont dit coûté l'ina on a vu ton
spectacle il faut que tu racontes avis
donc en 2013 ya aussi mon livre qui est
sorti longtemps j'ai habité dehors et
puis après tout s'est enchaîné
j'ai fait des conférences les sans
domicile fixe m'ont beaucoup aussi écrit
appelé pour j'allais les voir
et aujourd'hui je vous cache pas je suis
fier de mon parcours
même si je ne suis pas toujours fier
d'avoir fait des choses pour m'en sortir
est aujourd'hui souvent en 2015 je pense
souvent à mon ami la fiole qui me disait
l ena faut pas rêver quand on en a chié
on est toujours au bout du rouleau est
au bout du rouleau
c'est forcément le carton il me disait
ça mon ami la fiole
et ben moi je dis au contraire faut
rêver faut toujours aller au-delà du
possible parce que chaque fois qu'on va
au delà du possible on va toujours au
bout de ses rêves
merci